[Aplausos]
[Música]
tengo una pregunta si te hablo de la
unión europea que es en lo primero en lo
que piensas probablemente lo primero que
se te venga a la cabeza no se sean
imágenes de bruselas edificios públicos
o incluso estampas de países tan
importantes como alemania o francia
hasta es probable que dependiendo de
donde nos veas pienses antes en el reino
unido- que en países como por ejemplo
lituania o eslovenia y de hecho en 2018
se hizo una encuesta en 26 países de
todo el mundo cuyos resultados señalaban
que los tres estados de la unión más
importantes son por este orden alemania
francia y el reino unido- luego en
cuarta posición les seguía bastante de
lejos e italia todos ellos tienen como
denominador común que son países de la
europa occidental y lo cierto es que por
mucha unión que exista sobre el terreno
aún se palpa una marcada frontera entre
las dos europas tan distintas que hoy
por hoy integran la unión europea
hablamos de percepciones pero también de
infraestructuras y profundas diferencias
políticas sociales y económicas y esto
es algo amigos que preocupa cada vez más
en la otra europa la europa central y
oriental
y diréis pero qué es eso de las naciones
de los tres mares pues queridos amigos
amigas la iniciativa de los tres mares
es un proyecto que fue creado
precisamente para resolver todos estos
problemas viendo su nombre quizás
penséis no sé qué tiene que ver con algo
marítimo verdad pues lo siento pero no
nada de eso la iniciativa se llama así
porque une a doce países de la unión
europea ubicados entre tres males
distintos el mar báltico al norte el
negro por el sudeste y la didáctico por
el sudoeste hablamos de austria bulgaria
croacia eslovaquia eslovenia estonia
hungría letonia lituania polonia la
república checa y rumanía se trata de
una plataforma creada en 2015 para
llevar a cabo proyectos en tres ámbitos
infraestructuras energía y
telecomunicaciones su objetivo fomentar
el crecimiento económico de la región y
ya os adelanto que a pesar de ser
bastante reciente la iniciativa de los
tres mares ha dado lugar a más de una
polémica tanto dentro como fuera de la
unión europea
sintetizando este proyecto cuenta con el
apoyo de los eeuu que abre a mucho a
rusia y preocupa a algunos de los países
de la unión europea pero de dónde sale
este proyecto en qué consiste
exactamente hasta
donde puedes realmente llegar puede
quizás incluso convertirse en una
amenaza para la propia unión europea al
menos tal y como la conocemos pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
retorno de europa
tal y como hemos dicho la iniciativa de
los tres mares une a toda una franja de
países que van desde estonia hasta
bulgaria y desde luego la idea de
conectar el norte y el sur de europa es
de todo menos nueva lo que cambia en
esta ocasión es su promotor principal
que no es otro que polonia
el presidente duda polonia está en su
punto más fuerte desde el siglo 17
android duda es el presidente de polonia
el país que junto con croacia ha lanzado
la iniciativa de los tres mares y me
diréis pero qué diantres pinta aquí el
siglo 17 pues este mapa lo explica todo
lo que vemos en verde es el territorio
de la mancomunidad polaco lituana
hablamos de un estado federal creado por
la unión de lublín en el año 1569 éste
llegó a su máximo esplendor en el siglo
17 para polonia se trata de una época
dorada algo así como el siglo 20 para
hollywood sin embargo la mancomunidad
como tal tuvo una historia muy corta a
finales del siglo 18 este territorio vio
no una sino tres particiones entre sus
grandes vecinos austria prusia y rusia
como consecuencia tanto polonia como
lituania no volvieron a ser
independientes hasta la primera guerra
mundial en 1918 se creó la segunda
república polaca un estado independiente
que sin embargo no tenían nada que ver
con la grandeza del siglo 17 y fue
precisamente ahí cuando cobró peso la
idea de recrear de una u otra forma la
antigua mancomunidad
[Música]
como habría dicho donald trump si
hubiera nacido en la varsovia de la
época es nuevo si nick potts está bien
para que nos entendamos todos night pool
and write game aunque lo cierto es que
para hacer esta promesa no hizo falta un
donald trump porque la segunda república
polaca ya contaba con un líder
totalmente mentalizado con este mensaje
hablamos de youssef music
[Música]
liu si es que fue el primer jefe de
estado de la polonia del siglo 20 y su
gran preocupación se situaba en el este
en el imperio ruso primero y más tarde
en la unión soviética de hecho bajo el
mando de pixies que polonia libró una
guerra de dos años contra las futuras
repúblicas de la urss y claro la gran
pregunta es qué podría hacer un país
como polonia para sobrevivir pues amigos
music y tenían dos propuestas la primera
opción consistía en romper al enemigo
desde dentro ya sabéis que lo que se
refiere a las nacionalidades el imperio
ruso y más tarde el proyecto comunista
es grande todo menos homogéneos de esta
forma la idea del presidente polaco que
recibió el nombre me promete ismo
consistía en promover las actitudes anti
rusas y antisoviéticas en lo entre los
diferentes pueblos que integraban la
urss pero sin embargo el proyecto de
este presidente que más nos importa en
este vídeo es el llamado inter mario que
abarcaba el territorio que se encuentra
entre los mares báltico el mar negro y
el adriático ya que no suena esta franja
exacto son los mismos países que
participan hoy en la iniciativa de los
tres mares
[Música]
internar yo no me marché en polaco más o
menos fue un proyecto de federación
política entre los países situados en el
territorio de la antigua mancomunidad
por la cco lituana
de esta forma pills uts que pretendía
crear un nuevo núcleo de poder regional
y encontrar la fuerza en la unión eso sí
con polonia como la voz cantante esta
idea fue desarrollada por otros
políticos polacos en el período de
entreguerras pero la verdad es que no
encontró suficientes apoyos en el
exterior terminó convirtiéndose en un
proyecto fallido
[Música]
pero entonces porque estamos hablando de
él en visual polític pues amigos porque
para muchos analistas las ideas del
expresidente polaco son el antecedente
más claro de la iniciativa de los tres
mares juzgados por vosotros mismos
hablamos del mismo territorio de un
cierto antagonismo con rusia y un
proyecto con el que polonia tiene mucho
que ganar sin embargo existe
aparentemente una diferencia muy
importante entre inter marion y la
iniciativa de los tres mares y es que
prius qui pensaba en la integración de
los países de la región con las
vertientes geopolítica y militar como la
base del proyecto en cambio o la
iniciativa de los tres mares pues ya no
es un proyecto de integración sino de
coordinación y tiene un trasfondo mucho
más económico pero un momento porque
aquí aquí tenemos que hacer una
puntualización
es verdad que la nueva iniciativa no
prevé cooperación en materia militar
pero también es cierto que a excepción
de austria todos los países de la
iniciativa de los tres mares son también
miembros de la otan además nueve de
ellos forman parte de una agrupación
regional conocida como los nueve de
bucarest el 9 fue creado en 2015 a
propuesta de rumanía y como no también
de polonia y tiene como objetivo
armonizar las preferencias regionales en
el seno de la otan en otras palabras si
combinamos la iniciativa de los tres
mares con la membresía de estos países
en la otan y en el b 9 entonces lo que
tenemos es un proyecto mucho más
parecido a el intermedio
ahora bien llegados a este punto estoy
seguro de que aún tenéis muchas dudas
que es exactamente lo que implica esta
iniciativa ahora en el siglo 21 porque
le interesa tanto a polonia y qué
consecuencias puede tener para la región
y sobre todo para el exterior atentos
[Música]
conectando en europa
en 2015 de los presidentes de polonia y
de croacia acordaron crear la iniciativa
de los tres mares y hay que entender que
de momento pues no se trata de una nueva
organización internacional ni de nada
por el estilo sino de una plataforma
informal que trabaja a partir de cumbres
anuales su objetivo principal consiste
en fomentar el crecimiento económico en
la región y reducir su dependencia
energética de rusia muy importante por
eso sus tres tipos de proyectos clave
son los de transporte telecomunicaciones
y energía
a día de hoy hablamos de 90 proyectos en
distintas fases del desarrollo por
ejemplo uno de los proyectos propuestos
por hungría es la llamada conexión
norte-sur como indica su nombre consiste
en crear un corredor de transporte desde
suecia hasta grecia que pasaría a través
de polonia república checa eslovaquia
hungría croacia serbia montenegro y
macedonia y aunque algunos de estos
países ni siquiera forma parte de la
iniciativa de los tres mares lo que
importa aquí es el objetivo último
fomentar la conectividad entre el norte
y el sur de la franja centro oriental de
europa en el ámbito digital también
tenemos proyectos muy interesantes en
materias tan variadas como el 5g la
ciberseguridad y el monitoreo en tiempo
real de cuencas hidrográficas
pero quizás con mucha diferencia el
sector más importante es el de la
energía si sois seguidores ha sido
previsor polític conocéis bien el tema
de la seguridad energética en europa y
también sabéis cuál es una de sus
principales fuentes de gas por supuesto
me refiero a
[Música]
ni más ni menos que el 40 por ciento de
todo el gas que importa la unión europea
viene de rusia y tal y como podéis ver
el gas ruso es especialmente importante
para algunos de los países de la
iniciativa de los tres mares lo que se
traduce en una herramienta geopolítica
de incalculable valor para moscú
precisamente por esto países como
estonia letonia o croacia están
trabajando en la creación de terminales
de gas natural licuado que les permitan
no depender de los gasoductos y por
tanto del gas su uso amigos el gas
natural licuado o general del que ya
hemos hablado aquí en visual político te
transporta en gigantescos buques
metaneros y la ventaja de este sistema
consiste en que abre muchas nuevas vías
de importación por ejemplo desde el año
2017 polonia importa gas natural licuado
desde los eeuu hasta aquí y suena todo
genial verdad pues esto ha llegado el
momento de hablar del principal problema
de la iniciativa de los tres mares
[Música]
y es que algunos de los proyectos por
ejemplo el corredor norte-sur se
encuentran suspendidos porque no está
nada claro cómo y cuándo se van a
implementar y sobre todo de dónde
demonios saldrá el dinero para financiar
los recordad que ni siquiera hablamos de
una estructura formal a día de hoy sólo
se han finalizado dos de los 90
proyectos y ambos eran de alcance
nacional la solución integrada podría
ser ésta los bancos de polonia y de
rumanía establecen el fondo de
inversiones de la iniciativa de los tres
mares el fondo de inversiones fue creado
en junio del 2019 y es la primera
institución formal creada en el marco de
esta iniciativa inicialmente fue dotado
con 520 millones de euros una cifra que
ha ido creciendo hasta los 1200 millones
en el momento de preparar este vídeo
claro que aún están un poquito lejos de
su primer objetivo el cual se sitúa en
torno a los 3 mil millones de euros la
idea es que este fondo financie en sus
primeras etapas aproximadamente el 9 por
ciento de las inversiones planteadas el
resto de la financiación tendrá por
tanto que llegar de las arcas nacionales
y de fondos europeos tales como el banco
europeo de inversiones el banco europeo
para la reconstrucción y el desarrollo o
el mecanismo conectar europa claro que
si para algo ha servido ya este fondo ha
sido para constatar que el hay 3 eem la
iniciativa los tres mares y empieza a
despertar intereses
fuera de la región fijaos 300 millones
de dólares para el fondo de inversión de
la iniciativa de los tres mares de la
corporación financiera de desarrollo
internacional de eeuu queridos amigos
amigas porque le interesa tanto a los
eeuu hasta qué punto amenaza la
estabilidad dentro de la unión europea y
que tiene todo esto que ver con rusia
pues atentos
riesgo de inundaciones
hay 3 m aún siendo muy nueva está
empezando a suscitar reacciones de todo
tipo y es que no hablamos de poca cosa
en su conjunto la 3m está formada por 12
de los 27 países de la unión europea lo
que supone el 25 por ciento de la
población comunitaria y el 28 por ciento
de su territorio además a excepción de
austria todos estos países han entrado a
la unión europea a partir del 2004 de
tal forma que su historia como parte de
la unión comunitaria europea es bastante
pero que bastante reciente por eso la
creación de esta iniciativa ha sido
vista desde algunos países como un
intento de desafiar a la europa de los
15 es decir a los estados que formaban
parte de la unión europea antes del 2004
esta es por así decirlo la otra europa
que acoge la unión europea una europa
muy diferente a la que estamos
acostumbrados 1 europa amigos que no
siempre está cómoda con bruselas
ahora bien quiere decir eso que estamos
ante un proyecto que puede hacer temblar
los cimientos de la unión pues siendo
justo de momento hay que decir que no
parece que en el corto plazo vaya a ser
una amenaza para la unión europea
de momento no hablamos de una estructura
formal los pactos aún tiene un alcance
limitado y además no todos los países
están alineados en la misma dirección
por ejemplo eslovaquia y la república
checa- pues no forman parte todavía del
fondo de inversiones de la i 13m y esto
se explica en parte por su recelo ante
polonia y en menor medida también hacia
hungría y además la financiación de los
proyectos que se están poniendo en
marcha depende hoy por hoy en gran
medida de los fondos europeos pero un
momento porque eso no quiere decir que
esta iniciativa no pueda tener en el
medio plazo importantes consecuencias
light asm puede contribuir a cuestionar
a los países de europa del este-
empujarles en una misma dirección y
hacer crecer su peso en bruselas incluso
ha llegado el caso podrían ser todo un
contrapeso o podrían llegar a marcar
líneas rojas no olvidéis toda la
historia del próximo por ejemplo los
planes energéticos de la y 3m chocan con
el norte street 2 hace poco os
contábamos en visual política que el
norte string 2 es un gasoducto que
pronto llevará gas ruso a alemania a
pesar de las críticas que suscita en
europa central y amigos justo aquí justo
aquí entra en juego otro actor los
estados unidos'
mientras rusia espera mantener a
nuestros aliados europeos como rehenes
con su gasoducto nord stream 2 la
iniciativa de los tres mares busca
contrarrestar su influencia maligna adam
kinzinger miembro de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu para washington o
apoyar la iniciativa de los tres mares
es una buena oportunidad para
contrarrestar la influencia rusa en la
región tanto es así que noviembre del
2020 la cámara de representantes de los
eeuu aprobó por unanimidad una
resolución en favor del aicm por eso no
es de sorprender que el proyecto
preocupe mucho en rusia que sospecha que
los tres mares europeos podrían ahogar
sus intereses en esta región por ejemplo
en opinión del embajador ruso en estonia
la iniciativa de los tres mares podría
llegar a convertirse en todo un cordón
sanitario anti ruso y ya sabéis que esta
europa está mucho más conectada con
washington de lo que últimamente viene
siendo habitual en la antigua parte
occidental amigos europa del este- tiene
cada vez más peso su economía próspera y
su peso político no para de crecer
iniciativas como ésta aún cuando se
enfrenten a problemas de todo tipo para
arrancar pueden terminar convirtiéndose
en todo un punto de inflexión para la
política del viejo continente pero ha
llegado hasta aquí pregunta para ti
conocí es la iniciativa de los tres
mares creéis que podrá llevar a cabo
todos sus proyectos y tal vez la
pregunta más importante de todas creéis
llegar a ser una amenaza para la unión
europea podéis dejarnos por aquí abajo
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
ya sabéis si este vídeo se resulta
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a visor político una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]